Musik Herzlich willkommen.
Da war nicht aufgenommen die letzten 40 Minuten.
Also muss ich meine Zebra-Geschichte nochmal erzählen, meine lustige Anmoderation und das Unglück von Loch Ness 2003.
Okay, ich bin bereit.
Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe des Das Podcast UFOos, wie wir es intern nur noch nennen. DPU. DPU. Also würden wir euch bitten, das auch zu übernehmen einfach. Uns hat übrigens jemand ein 8-Bit-Info geschickt. Ja, mega bam ja mega gut ja haben wir noch nie benutzt alle Podcasts würden das sofort reinhauen
die erste Woche nachdem das kam würden die das sofort reinhauen das Intro nö wir einfach
komplett ignoriert einfach sollten wir eigentlich für diese Folge reinhauen oder
jetzt hörte noch mal ein Intro das normale noch mal aus Gag einfach und danach hörte das
8-Bit-Intro, Mark the Difference. Das war schön, oder? Da hat er sich wirklich Mühe gegeben, der Mario. Der, hier in einem Einfügen. Also jetzt kann man mal statistisch an die Sache rangehen. Wir machen heute mal ein Resümee. Ne, mathematisch fundiert würde ich mal an die Sache rangehen. Wie heisst der am ehesten? Was ist der häufigste Jungenname Deutschlands? Ich würde sagen Max. Philipp oder sowas. Also es gibt schon sehr viele Philipps. Max, Andreas, Klaus, Stefan. Sagen wir Urs. Und als Nachname, was ist der häufigste Nachname? Müller wahrscheinlich oder Schmidt. Also heisst er wahrscheinlich Ursi! Urs Schmidt. Ursi! Vielen Dank für das 8-Bit-Intro. Ja, fand ich ein bisschen zu wenig Bit. Haben wir das jetzt eingespielt oder nicht? Ja, ja, haben wir das jetzt eingespielt. Zweimal allerdings aus Versehen. Ach, es ist so crazy, diese Schnittgags, die man machen kann. Unglaublich. Und damit weiss ich auch nicht mehr. Ja, ich glaube, der grösste Schnittgag wird sein, dass einfach alles rausgeschnitten wird und wir einfach gleich nochmal neu anmoderieren, oder? Ja, darauf wird es hinauslaufen. So. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu einer neuen Folge von DPU, Ihr Podcast für gute Laune, DPU, frisch geliefert zu ihnen nach hause dpu für gross
und klein und alt dpu wir singen das zerschalt und dpu ja lustig, u. Ich lache mich immer noch kaputt, hahaha. Ja gut, herzlich willkommen, naja, schade wenn man auf dem Dauna eint. Es ist mega früh heute, wir sind neben um zehn Uhr gerade auf. Wir sind gerade aufgestanden, ich habe jetzt gerade schon ein Mohnbrötchen im Mund. Wie kamst du dem Mohnbrötchen, was hat dich geritten, heute mal so aus deiner normalen Usus abzuweichen? Was hat dich geritten, Mohnbrötchen zu bestellen? Ist das eine Frage? Ja, Stefan ist ein sehr, sehr ordnungsliebender, prinzipientreuer Mensch und dass der hier mal mit einem schönen Mohnbrötchen hier in die Kabine stolziert, das sieht man selten, was passiert. Normalerweise, ich liebe Laugenbrötchen, normalerweise nämlich zwei Laugenbrötchen jeden Morgen, heute hatte ich nur Geld für ein Brötchen dabei und die hatten keine Laugenbrötchen mehr, nur ein Laugenbrötchen mit Mohn bereits. Was auch echt ein komisches Sortiment ist, quasi keine Laugenbrötchen zu haben, aber dafür Laugenbrötchen mit Mohn direkt. Ja. Das ist doch wesentlich spezieller. Was Stefan hier in dem Nebensatz angerissen hat, ist der finanzielle Ruin, der sich Stefan immer näher nähert, denn, was ja viele nicht mitbekommen haben, der Aktienmarkt schwankt. Und Stefan Titze ist mittendrin auf seinem kleinen Boot, sitzt er mitten in den riesigen Wellen der Frankfurter Börse und versucht noch seinen Segel hochzuhalten. Stefan ist nämlich Aktionär geworden. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Stefan, erstmal! Dankeschön, aber komm jetzt die ganzen Kollegen hier an mich rein. Ja, natürlich, komm rein, Johanna, komm mal rein! Happy Birthday to you, nein, nein, nein, Aktien, Aktien, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Geld, Aktien, Aktien, Geld, stille Rividende, an der Börse, lieber Ste... Danke. Auch die T-Shirts waren schön, also mit meinem Gesicht da drauf fand ich ganz gut, mit dem Geldaugen, bei den Dollarzeichen in den Augen, tolle Idee. Spreadshirt, wie habt ihr das gemacht? Ich glaube, wir haben es auf spreadshirt.com slash daspodcastdokon.php at stefan hat die URL gestaltet.
Aktionär zu sein ist, sag ich mal, nichts für schwache Nerven.
Man sitzt da wirklich in seinem kleinen Kutter, in seinem kleinen Dampfer,
und ringsherum passieren Mächte am Werk, von denen du nicht so viel verstehst auch. Das ist ein bisschen so, als ob du in so einer, weiss nicht, in so einem kleinen, wenn du als Kind den Karton gebaut hast, einen Rennwagen daraus, aber halt alles sein gelassen hast mit dem Rennwagen, sondern einfach nur, dass du dich in den Karton gesetzt hast und einfach den Rest des Tages herumgeschoben wirst, weil du auch im Weg stehst, so fühlt das ein bisschen. Aber du profitierst ja auch von den Mächten, die neben dir arbeiten. Du musst es ja gar nicht verstehen, du musst nur schön die Hand in den Regen halten und schön die Taler in deinen Sack fallen lassen. So funktioniert das doch. Ja, genau. Es ist ja ein konstanter Geldregen und du musst eigentlich nur zugreifen. Wie hast du es gemacht? Ich habe mich gut informiert, die richtigen Entscheidungen getroffen. Das ist wichtig. Du willst nicht sagen, welche Aktien du gekauft hast. Nein, das ist mein Tipp auch für die Leute draußen. Trefft die richtigen Entscheidungen an der Börse. Das ist immer. Die meisten Leute treffen die falschen Entscheidungen. Und da fängt es nämlich an. Die Kenner treffen die richtigen Entscheidungen. Tipp eins. Das stimmt. Erinnert mich eine lustige Geschichte, die ich in Folge sieben schon mal erzähle, die ich einfach nochmal erzähle, weil sie sehr gut war. Also wir haben uns heute vorgenommen, einfach mal alle Geschichten nochmal zu erzählen. So eine Art Best-of einfach nochmal zurückzuschauen. Ja. Oder so ein Medium-of. Best-of würde eigentlich heißen, dass wir die Clips von damals nehmen nochmal einspielen, wir erzählen die Geschichten aber einfach nochmal. Ja, und zwar wurde ein guter Freund von mir, der sowieso schon nicht so gut in der Schule war und so ein bisschen der Slacker war, aber so ein bisschen cooler Typ eigentlich, der hatte auch als erstes eine Freundin. Und wie hieß der komische Florentin Bill vielleicht? Florentin Bill und das war ein ziemlich cooler Typ, aber der hatte halt so ein bisschen Probleme in der Schule. Da war immer eine Abfrage bei der schrecklichsten Lehrerin ever in der Abfrage, alleine vorne und dann wurde er gefragt auf Französisch. Es war ein anderes Fahr, aber er wurde auf Französisch gefahren.
Da hieß es, wenn du in Paris mit der Metro fährst, auf welcher Seite musst du aussteigen? Und er, natürlich die Geschichte nicht gelesen, sagt, links, nee, okay, rechts, nee, Na, weil er oben übers D was, und die richtige Antwort lautete, man muss auf der richtigen Seite aussteigen. Da stand halt in der Geschichte irgendwie, Babette rät ihrem Freund Tim, du musst immer auf der richtigen Seite aussteigen, und das war dann die Vokabel. Danke, Babette. Ja, danke, vielen Dank, du sterben. Danke, die dumme Fotze Babette, ey. Genau, und das war dann die richtige Antwort, aber das war auch so ein, ja gut, eine Sechs abgeholt für nichts einfach. Das ist ja auch eine Eins hätte sein können. Ja, genau, du kannst auch einfach bei Mathe irgendwie richtig schreiben, ist gleich die richtige Lösung. Aber wie ging dir das, wenn ein Lehrer eine sehr einfache Frage, eine vermeintlich sehr einfache Frage gestellt hat? Das ist nie vorgekommen. Die Fragen waren für mich immer extrem schwer zu machen. Du hast auch bayerisches Abitur. Ich habe ja NRW-Abitur. Ich kann die Gänse für mich nicht gross genug sprechen. Abitur. Kann man das noch grösser sprechen? Erbittlich jetzt mal, ernstige Frage. Du hast zwei Mikrofone in der Hand, das funktioniert auch nicht so gut, technisch. NRW-Abitur. Ja, das war schon ein bisschen am Anschlag, glaube ich. Ja, das war schon irgendwie das Extrem. Und da wurden manchmal sehr einfache Fragen gestellt, auf die ich dann nie antworten wollte, weil ich mir denke, das ist jetzt nicht sein Ernst. Doch, eine Geschichte, die ich in Folge 3 erzählt habe, glaube ich, und zwar hatte ich mündliches Abitur in Wirtschaft und Recht und es klingt wie ein Gag und klingt wie ein Klischee, ist aber wirklich so passiert. Hab ich auf eine Banane ausgerutscht und vor dem Tisch der Lehrer hingefallen.
Genau, und bin dann auf die Lehrerin gefallen und die hat mir dann im letzten Atemzug noch eine einzige gegeben. Und zwar war angegeben, haben wir so Infos bekommen, was wir lernen sollten. Und dann stand da Seite 23 bis 116 oder sowas. Und dann habe ich die Seiten gelernt und habe am Tag der mündlichen Prüfung erfahren, dass wir alles ausser diese Seiten hätten lernen sollen. Also wirklich, ist es wirklich genauso passiert. Ich erinnere mich an diese tolle Geschichte, wo ich sehr dankbar bin, dass sie noch mal erzählt. Auf jeden Fall. Und dann hatte ich überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, bin in die Abfrage gegangen, da war eine Frage, wenn sie von einem Bauern ein Schwein klauen und mit diesem Schwein in der Hand den Bauernhof verlassen. Und dann zieht ein Gewitter auf. Und währenddessen fährt Paul mit 200 kmh in Düsseldorf los. Auf jeden Fall ist sie ein Gewitter auf. Ist eine andere Geschichte. Und ein Blitz schlägt auf das Schwein ein und tötet es. Müssen sie Schadensersatz leisten? Das war die Frage. Wirtschaft und Recht. Ich war gerade auch in der Englisch. Wirtschaft und Recht. Und ich dann, ja, ja, richtig. Danke, wow. Das war immer so, normaler Menschenverstand hat mir da noch, glaube ich, die drei Punkte irgendwo gesichert oder so. Also das war auch wahrscheinlich auch so eine Mitleidsfrage. Ja, so trottel. Aber auch so, die Story driftet immer mehr ab irgendwie. Und dann kommt ihr toller Ex-Mann und sagt, nein, dafür gibt es keinen Schadensersatz, das müssen Sie alle selber zahlen. Und ich sag Dominik. Auch klasses, Classic Dominik, naja, Classic Dominik. Man kann doch auch als Lehrer dann, finde ich, in so mündlichen Abitur fragen, einfach auch sehr private Fragen, die ja immer schon Beschäftigt haben, einfach stellen. Würden Sie, wenn Sie jetzt an der Börse aktiv wären, Telekom Aktien kaufen, ja oder nein? Jetzt hatte ich gerade eine gute Story, aber jetzt habe ich es vergessen, weil du mir so intensiv in die Augen geschaut hast. Man muss auch mal sagen, viele Leute wissen ja nicht so genau, wie Stefan aussieht, aber Stefan hat sehr eindringliche Augen. Stefan hat wirklich Augen, die schauen einem wirklich in die Seele hinein. Die schauen einem durch, richtig durch. Ja, die schauen durch und Stefan hat in seinen Augen so einen gewissen Funken, den man ganz schwer beschreiben kann. Das ist so eine Mischung aus Verzweiflung, Depression und Angst. Das hat so etwas ganz Flatterhaftes, wie so eine Flamme, die kurz vorm Ersticken ist. Das hat so ein bisschen die Natur von Stefans Augen. Ja, Florentins Augen sind sehr milchig, so glasig, so leicht, immer so ein bisschen daneben einfach gucken, auch nie dich direkt an, sondern immer so durchdurch. Das sind so Florentins Augen, sehr müde, also sehr kleine Augen. Ja, ich habe gestern erfahren, dass alle Augen gleich gross sind.
Alle Menschen haben die exakt grosse Augapfelform.
Aber wenn du sagst, du hast kleine Augen …
Dann beschreibt man eher die Lage der Augen innerhalb des Schädels.
Ja, oder auch einfach die Hautöffnung vorne der Augen.
Wie nennt man die Hautöffnung?
Iris.
Nein, Lied.
Ines. Ach ja, Augen. Warte mal, ich habe ein paar Sachen eigentlich zu erzählen. Kannst du jetzt erst deinen Laptop auspacken, das ist wirklich schlecht möglich zur Vorbereitung. Ich war heute Morgen so ein bisschen gemütlich drauf einfach. Ich brauche den einfach jetzt nicht. Ich habe mir auch in meinen Kaffee so ein bisschen so einen kleinen Jack Daniels angekippt und einfach so ein bisschen den Tag. Na, hab ich nicht. Nimmt mir auch niemanden ab. Was ist deine Beziehung zu Alkohol eigentlich? Können wir da mal drauf eingehen? Ich war einmal bei dir zu Hause und du hattest eine Minibar rumstehen und da waren Glasflaschen gefüllt mit Flüssigkeit. Da hab ich gesagt, ah, was ist das? Scotch, Whisky, Bourbon und du ja, Apfelschor. Ja, ach, ich finde, ich bin Alkohol mittlerweile relativ abgeneigt. Also ich trinke es nicht gern. Die meisten Sachen schmecken mir auch nicht so. Und ich bin einfach nicht gerne mit betrunkenen Menschen in einem Raum, weil die unberechenbar sind und ich auch unberechenbar bin. Und das gefällt mir nicht. Warum bist du unberechenbar? Wenn man Alkohol trinkt, ist man unberechenbar.
Okay, ich dachte, es klang so, als wäre, ja, betrunkene Leute sind unberechenbar und ich bin auch unberechenbar. Ich bin auch ein ziemlich unberechenbar Typ. Von daher ist es eine toxische Mischung. Nee, aber ich glaube, die einzigen Sachen, wo man, also ich trinke Whisky einfach gern. Das ist was, was ich einfach mag. Und da habe ich mir irgendwann mal so zwei, drei Whiskyflaschen, verschiedene Sorten gekauft, einfach und habe mir so coole Gläser gekauft, weil sie einfach cool aussieht und so mit Eiswürfeln. Das ist schon ganz geil. Ich fand den Lifestyle aber cooler auch als alles andere daran. Und seitdem stehen die da halt rum. Wie viele Dinge, die ich mir einfach aus so einem Impuls, aus so einem Lifestyle-Impuls gekauft habe. Aber klar, aber es passt auch gut zu dir. Sitzst dann dann mit deinem Smoking, mit so einem Don-Draper-Glas und so und in der linken Hand noch dein Lichtschwert und irgendwie dein ATS hier aus Lego, irgendwie schaust dir Family Guy und trinkst einfach ganz sophisticated einen Whisky. Kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Mhm, passt alles zusammen. Es ist ein sehr schlüssiges Bild, was man von mir hat.
Ja.
Du trinkst auch gar nicht, ne?
Nee.
Warum ist das so? Weil ich habe es von vielen Leuten gehört, die das machen, was wir machen und die nicht trinken. Und ich vermute da ein Muster. Ich vermute da ein ganz, genau wie das so ist, dass die meisten Leute, die in der Comedy arbeiten, ihren Vater verloren haben. Und du hast deinen Vater auch verloren, kann man jetzt mal sagen? Ja, einfach. Wir haben uns damals getrennt, im Disneyland haben wir uns nicht mehr gesehen und seitdem einfach, ich habe keinen Kontakt. Damals auch im Supermarkt habe ich die verloren, dann haben meine Eltern aus dem Auge verloren, dann habe ich nie wieder gesehen. Zehn für zehn Minuten lang und dann waren sie wieder da, seltsamerweise. Ich habe mich letztens daran erinnert, was für ein scheiss Kind ich eigentlich war. Also manchmal kommen so ein paar Erinnerungsfetzen hoch und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass wir mein neues Zimmer, ich bin ja irgendwann in den Keller gezogen, zu meinen Geschwistern, also zu meinen Zwillingen, bin ich in den Keller gezogen, dann sollten wir einen Teppich aussuchen, dann waren wir in diesem Teppichladen und ich weiss noch, dass ich ohne Grund angefangen habe zu heulen in diesem Teppichladen und meine Eltern und ich fragte mich dann, was ist denn los und ich weiss nicht warum, ich weiss nicht warum, ich jetzt weine, aber ich weine jetzt. Und habe ich einmal geheult. Und ich weiss nicht genau, warum. Ich hatte irgendwie einfach das Bedürfnis zu weinen. Und es war meinen Eltern wahrscheinlich mega unangenehm, dass ihr Kind in so einem grossen Teppichladen, in Teppichläden, wo man ja normalerweise extrem glücklich ist, fröhlich als Kind auch, und dass ich da weine, das wahrscheinlich total unangenehm für die war. Aber ich weiss noch genau, dass ich damals gesagt habe, ich weiss nicht, warum ich jetzt weine. Das ist ein Scheisskind. Das ist ein Megascheisskind, kann man auch nichts machen. Ich erinnere mich an eine Szene, wie ich, wie ich, Szene, das wäre mein ganzer Leben ein Film gewesen, wie ich damals auf einer Hochzeit war und es war alles leise, war in einer Kirche und dann habe ich einfach in eine Zigarette gefasst, einfach so in eine Zigarette meines Vaters einfach so reingefasst mit der Hand und dann einfach angefangen zu heulen, als wäre das das Schlimmste der Welt, was es für ein Kind auch glaube ich auch ist, einfach so eine Zigarette zu... Weil du warst 70. Das ist schon hart, so letzte Woche, aber gut, das ist schon glaube ich ziemlich hart, weil du schaffst dir einen Grund zu heulen und da weichst dir glaube ich ein bisschen voraus, weil ich nicht einfach geheult habe, sondern erst ja, dann fahre ich halt in Zigarette. Du hast die Kausalkette verstanden, ich verstehe schon, das ist nicht doof. Ne, die habe ich übersprungen, einfach, ich habe direkt, ich will weinen, also weine ich. Was machst du im Moment, wie verbringst du deine Tage, wie verbringst du deine Nächte, wie verbringst du... Ich bin gerade in so einer Inputphase, ich schaue ganz viele Sachen an, ich schaue verschiedene Serien an, verschiedene Filme an, ich habe mir gestern Horrorfilme angeschaut, weil mir der empfohlen wurde, ich hasse Horrorfilme, schaue die nie.
The Witch habe ich mir angeschaut, so von 2015 hat er auch irgendwie so Cannenpreis bester Regisseur gewonnen und so und wurde mir von, mein Mitbewohner ist so, der macht so Special Make-up, so Masken und so und shit und ist total Horrorfan und der hat mir den empfohlen, so der ist total krass und so und total und da dachte ich mir, okay, das hat er noch, man ist dann irgendwie doch noch 13 und sagt, wenn jemand sagt so, ey, der ist so krass, der Film, hat man dieses, ja okay, Mutprobe, ich muss den angucken, wo man sich denkt, hallo, ich bin viel zu alt für solche Gedankenmuster, aber man denkt sich dann, ja gut, man doch und dann schaut man sich den an und denkt sich, okay, du musst einfach nur durchkommen und dann hatte ich, aber habe ich mir illegal angeschaut und dann habe ich tatsächlich, weil der so eine schlechte Qualität hatte, habe ich den Film lang viel mehr über Videocodierung nachgedacht als über den Film selbst, weil der hatte dann immer so Fragmente, die dann immer so gesprungen sind, was ja daraus kommt, dass bei der Videocodierung das Codierungssystem versucht zu errechnen, der Unterschied zwischen den Frames und immer nur den Unterschied abspeichert, aber nicht das ganze Bild. Und dann immer, je nachdem wie hoch die Toleranz ist, dann diesen Unterschied auch immer dann höher oder niedriger tolerant behandelt. Also wenn alles weiss ist, auch weiss, dann hat er überhaupt keine Infos. Aber wenn es sich so ein bisschen bewegt, dann macht er das so ein bisschen schlampig, dass du halt manchmal diese Fragmente hast, die dann so sprunghaft sind, weil der dann immer denkt, okay, das muss ich nicht berechnen als Differenz. Und darüber habe ich mir Gedanken gemacht. Aber was viele auch nicht wissen, wenn du, wenn du halt, viele illegale Filme sind ja auch abgefilmt im Kino und dann laufen manchmal auch Leute von der Leinwand vor. Und was viele auch nicht wissen, eine Kodierung versucht, die Kodierung versucht dann, diese Leute in den Film einzubauen. Richtig. Die kriegen auch Sprechrollen und so. Wie kriegen die, genau, die gehen in den Text und so, versuchen einfach, okay, kriegen wir das am schlauesten in den Film, weil die Kodierungen sind ja auch nicht blöd. Genau, und auch das Husten, wenn Leute im Kino husten, versuchen die die Leute auch husten zu lassen. Dann gehen die kurz drauf ein, sagen Gesundheit und dann machen die weiter mit dem Video. Ja genau, sagt man eigentlich nicht bei Husten, aber was soll's und dann gut, aber wir müssen irgendwie rein. Also vier Minuten länger, illegale Varianten sind meistens wesentlich länger. Wesentlich länger, acht Stunden länger. Also ich finde, ich fand den Film gar nicht so schlecht,, aber... Empfehlungen haben wir jetzt nicht so... Wie viele Popcorn-Tüten von Tacos? Also kriegt von mir zwei Popcorn-Tüten und ein Taco und vier Prozent und drei Daumen nach oben und vierzehn Daumen nach unten. Also ich bin kein Horrorfilm-Fan, deswegen möchte ich ungeheuer Horrorfilm empfehlen, aber wenn man da aufsteht, vielleicht nicht. Aber es ist echt unangenehm, weil man... das war so der Trick, weil ich hatte auch immer... Als Kind war ich sehr ängstlich, aber manchmal gruselige Filme gesehen, aber der Tipp, den mein Vater gegeben hat, ist immer, denk immer dran, dass das einfach nur ein Film ist, da steht da links ein gelangweilter Prakti, der gerade ein Sandwich isst, rechts neben der Kamera steht ein Aufnahmeleiter, der sagt, okay Leute, wir müssen jetzt noch einen Cake machen, dann sind wir durch. Führ dir das einfach vor Augen, dann ist das gar nicht mehr so schlimm. Und jetzt bin ich Schritt weiter, jetzt denke ich eher über die Videokodierung nach. Und so verliert dieser Film auch ganz schnell seinen Schrecken. Bei mir war das anders. Meine Eltern hatten oft mehr Angst vor dem Film als ich. Und da musste ich meine Eltern auch sagen, das ist nur ein Film und ist auch gar nicht so schlimm. Ja, das ist kein echtes Blut. Vor allem, warum haben Christen überhaupt Angst vor Horrorfilmen? Also erst mal haben sie ja gegen Werwölfe und so immer Geheimwaffen, weil sie einfach den Kreuz in die Fresse halten und dann sind die tot oder Silberpfeile oder so einen Scheiss. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn die Leute sterben, wovon man ja die meiste Angst hat bei einem Horrorfilm, das sind Leute sterben, die man mag, weil die Protagonisten cool sind und sympathische Titrediger sind. Wenn die sterben, haben die aber ein besseres Leben. Das ist ja das Christendenkel. Wow, wenn man stirbt, hat man die bessere Denkel. Ich glaube, es ist etwas sehr einfach gedacht, dass man da sagt, nur weil Christen anhanden, dass sie dann sterben wollen. Ich glaube, ganz so allein ist es dann doch nicht. Da hast du im Religionsunterricht nicht aufgepasst. Das ist nicht der Sinn der Sache. Ich glaube, der Sinn des Lebens ist zu sterben, um dann in den Himmel zu kommen. Oh, das ist sehr tiefgründig. Das ist sehr gut gesagt. Aber es ist tatsächlich interessant. Das sagte er während einer Kampfs-Kaffeetasse trank. Das ist auch echt... Ich glaube, du kannst nicht tiefgründig. Das ist ja sehr gut gesagt. Aber es ist tatsächlich interessant. Sagte er während er so einer Kamps Kaffeetasse trank. Das ist auch echt, wenn Kant… Ich glaube, du kannst nicht tiefgründig wirken, während du gerade eine Kamps Kaffebecher trinkst. Kampff. Wenn du gerade meinen Kampf liest, aber wenn Kant jetzt zum Beispiel seine Mega-Sachen rausgehauen hat, seine grössten Hits, Char-Cho, Best of, Immanuel Kant. Best of, wie zum Beispiel, was sind deine 72 Lieblings-Kant-Zitate? Boah, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Ich will einfach direkt bei Platz 1 einsteigen. Und zwar, benutze deine Vernunft, du dummes Arschloch. Das war glaube ich sein Bestes. Aber wie kam, also der hat das ja auch nicht gesagt, während er irgendwie gerade mit seinen Oropax am Rumfriemeln war. Wie kommst du jetzt auf Oropax? War einfach irgendwo in meinem Kopf gerade, aber ... Kant, Kanti, Kantinga, was ist los, Immanuel, Manu? Ach, ich hätte wieder eine gute Idee für einen Satz. Ja, hau mal raus einen Satz. Bin ich erst mal gespannt, was du für einen Satz bist. Pass mal, lass auf dich ergehen, also nicht sofort lachen, lass es erst mal auf dich erwirken, handle nur nach dererlei Maxime, von denen du wollen kannst, dass sie zum allgemeinen Gesetz werden. Das war jetzt der erste Entwurf. Was genau ist eine Maxime? Ja, das ist ja jetzt erst mal egal. Ist deine Freundin oder was? Kommt dann, ja. wie klingt der Satz für dich? Ich finde es romantisch. Romantisch? Ja, ist ein schöner Satz. Was ist denn deine ersten Assoziationen zu einem Satz? Ja, finde ich schön. Schön. Handeln stets nach derjenigen Maxime, von der du wollen kannst, das überhaupt nicht. Wie würdest du das interpretieren? Ich muss ja verstanden werden, weißt du, das ist ja so ein bisschen mein Lebenselixier. Also ich muss ja verstanden werden von den Leuten, das ist ein bisschen mein... Leit Lebenselixier? Ja, also die müssen mich verstehen, sonst ist man als Philosoph auf verlorenen Posten unterwegs, ist doch klar. Ach, ich wusste gar nicht, dass du Philosoph bist, sorry, ich dachte, du hast diesen Podcast und so, machst aber... Nee, ich bin hauptberuflich Philosoph. Ach was? Ja. Ah cool, was machst du so? Ja, ich entwickle Sätze wie handeln noch dererlei Maxime von dem du wollen kannst habe ich jetzt drei Jahre für gebraucht für den Satz deswegen wäre es mir schon ganz wichtig dass du den gut findest als mein bester Freund Joe also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel denke alle Menschen sollten also wenn ich gerne vergewaltige ja und sagt vergewaltigen ist supergeil dann könnte ich das nur machen, wenn ich wollen könnte, dass alle anderen auch vergewaltigen würden.
Dass alle anderen auch dich vergewaltigen.
Hätte ich jetzt nichts dagegen.
Du würdest gerne vergewaltigt werden?
Ja, klar.
Wollen wir dann einfach kurz nebenan an die Scheune?
Klassisches Wie beende ich diesen Sketch-Symptom?
Billiger Sex-Gag.
Sie müssen irgendwie den Raum verlassen, Hauptsache wie, ist mir scheissegal wie. We cut into the room. Ja. We cut into the room. Ja, alles klar. Dankeschön, Florentin Will. Cunt ist dein Lieblingsphilosoph, kannst du was mit anfangen? Ich kenne mich viel zu wenig mit Philosophie aus, um das zu sagen zu können, aber nein. Ich glaube, ich bin noch zu pragmatisch, um mich an sowas aufzuhalten. Ich glaube, so Moralphilosophie ist nicht so mein Ding. Wenn, dann eher Utilitarismus. Sehe ich mich eher. Also eher so Hitler direkt umbringen als Kind, stechen auf das Neugeborene direkt ein, stechen. Kurz nach der Geburt einfach direkt mit einem Messer ins Gesicht, einfach sagen, Frau Hitler, sorry. Sorry, aber ihr Sohn ist ein Riesenarschloch, der mit einer Menge Leute umbringt, so ist besser. Ich bringe sie am besten auch noch auf. Ich hätte, glaube ich, nicht Arsch, ich hätte Heiopei gesagt. So ein Riesen-Heiopei. So ein Riesen-Dussel, immer ein bisschen daneben. Doofkopf, einfach. Ja, aber das ist, ich glaube, also ich finde es auch sinnvoller, also erstmal glaube ich nicht, dass man wie Kant handeln kann überhaupt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Gut, wer bin ich jetzt, kann es widersprechen, das ist eine sehr gute Frage, Florian, danke, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Menschen sich selber verlassen können, so viel Empathie zeigen können, um sich vorstellen zu können, was wäre, wenn alle Menschen so handeln würden. So, glaube ich, ticken Menschen nicht. Die sind einfach so egoistische, dumme Arschlöcher und das ist aber manchmal auch gar nicht so schlecht, weil du kannst doch gute Dinge vollbringen, um dir selber was Gutes zu tun. Ich glaube auch, dass wenn Leute spenden, die das nicht aus Altruismus machen, sondern nur weil sie selber was Gutes tun wollen und das ist auch gut, also es gibt ja auch sinnvollen Egoismus und deswegen glaube ich, dass es nicht wirklich ist. Ja, du hast ja mal die gewagte These aufgestellt, dass es keinen Altruismus gibt, dass es nur Egoismus gibt. Ja, und der Meinung bin ich immer noch. Das hast du damals in New York in der U-Bahn gesagt. Habe ich eine Frau ins Gesicht geschrieben, glaube ich. War ziemlich cool, ja. Ich weiß es noch. Aber du hast eine Menge Geld bekommen. Also es war ganz geil eigentlich. Wenn ich bei Mac Drive mit meinem Auto quasi erstmal meine Bestellung durchgegebe, dann fange ich auch an, erstmal diese philosophische These auszustellen.
Genau, ja, aber erst beim zweiten Schalter.
Erst beim zweiten Schalter, ja.
Der zweite Schalter ist auch immer der bessere Schalter.
Das ist der Philosophie-Schalter. Hier können Sie Ihre gewagten Thesen reinsprechen.
Der ist richtig gut. Ja, so ein Theorie-Telefon wäre eigentlich auch ganz gut, wo Leute anrufen ihre Theorien und dann irgendjemand selektiert das und macht dann ein Buch draus, so die anonyme Theorien von Stefan Titzel, sowas.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Weil nur ich angerufen, weil ich nur diese Nummer kenne, weil es mein Handy ist.
Deine Mailbox.
Was eigentlich mit User-Input? Warum sagen wir nicht mal, Leute schickt uns eure besten Theorien und wir überprüfen sie, ob sie Bestand haben oder nicht?
Ja, weil du wieder ab Minute zwei anfängst, unsere Hörer massiv zu beleidigen.
Ja und? Wenn die Theorie scheisse ist, dann muss man das auch sagen.
Ja, aber können wir gerne mal machen. Ich bin ja immer für User-Kategorien, du lehnst die mal ab, kategorisch. Der kategorische Ablehrer-Lativ. Hm, nicht schlecht, gerade noch gerettet hat. Mehr Sinn gegeben, als du wahrscheinlich dachtest, dass es tut. Ja! Ja! Haut mal was raus, Leute. Ihr sitzt da immer nur rum, fett und bräsig, mit Butter im Gesicht und Käse tropft euch auf die Hose. Wenn ihr überhaupt eine Hose anhabt, haut mal was raus, Leute. Ihr sitzt da immer nur rum, fett und bräsig mit Butter im Gesicht und Käse tropft euch auf die Hose, wenn ihr überhaupt eine Hose anhabt. Haut mal was raus, haut mal eure Theorien raus. Ich meine, ihr könnt ja auf der Puffopedia nachgucken, da haben wir noch eine Menge Theorien gesammelt, die wir im Laufe der Zeit gesammelt haben. Die Donut-Mensch-Theorie zum Beispiel, die ganzen Klassiker und Hits. Haut mal ein paar eigene Theorien raus, schickt uns mal ein paar Sachen, die ihr so mit euch mitnehmt und die ihr diskutiert. Haut mal einfach was raus über Facebook, Twitter, Instagram oder auf WordPress. Haut mal was raus und dann können wir mal so ein bisschen schauen, was hat unsere Community eigentlich drauf. Das wollen wir bei EMA machen. Wir wollen nächste Woche zum ersten Mal einen Periscope-Stream machen, die haben wir jetzt erfunden. Und wir machen dann live einen Periscope-Stream, Mittwochabend, acht Uhr, und wir sind gespannt auf euer Input. Periscope ist dieses ... Periscope. Aber das haben U-Boote, um über die Wasseroberfläche schauen zu können, ne? Genau. Damit die anderen U-Boote wissen, wo sie hinschießen müssen. Ja, damit man diesen coolen Effekt hat, dass wie so ein Erdmännchen jemand hochkommt und sich dreht. Das habe ich mehr für den Gag als für alles andere. Oh, bitte, Herr Leutnant, kann ich ans Periskop, bitte. Ich kann das so gerne, bitte, ich würde nur mal gucken. Das ist schon das durfte Mal heute, dass Sie mich fragen. Sie sind eigentlich der Koch hier an Bord. Ja, aber ich würde auch mal rausgucken, das macht so viel Spaß. Ich will mal wieder den Himmel sehen. Also eigentlich sollen wir so, ich habe den Auftrag bekommen, dass wir so wenig wie möglich rausgucken sollen, weil Leute, Feinde sehen uns.
Wir haben keine Feinde, wir sind Schweden.
Aber der Sinn eines U-Boots ist, dass man nicht gesehen wird, deswegen ist man unter Wasser die ganze Zeit.
Ja, ich weiss, ja.
Einmal noch, ein einziges Mal noch.
Oh danke, das ist sehr nett.
Hier sind die Schlüssel, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das ...
Komplexeste Periskop der Welt. Das sind die Schlüssel. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das hält.
Komplexeste Periskop der Welt.
Nicht so weit raus.
Wir wissen nicht genau, was ein Periskop ist.
Nicht so weit rausschwimmen!
Wir wissen auch nicht genau, wie lang es ist.
Vierzig, vierhundert Meter lang.
Es dauert sehr lange, bis es so ausgefahren ist. That's what she said. Oh Gott. Okay. Aber du hast ja, hast du dir als Kind auch mal so Um-die-Ecke-Gucker gebaut. Ja. Ich glaube im Mickey-Maus-Magazin, so mit so zwei Spiegel, wo du dann Um-die-Ecke-Gucken konntest. Es hieß, es hat den schlauen Namen Um-die-Ecke-Guck-Rohrr, ohne Scheiss. Guck Apparatus. Und es war immer sehr schwierig, das von meinen Freunden zu leihen, weil ich mich auch versprochen habe und dann einfach einen Löffel bekommen habe und so, weil ich wollte eigentlich das Um die Ecke Guck Rohr haben. Aber es war auch irgendwie so fünf Zentimeter lang, war es auch so. Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar verlängert auf eigener Faust. Ich habe da noch so eine Küchenrollen, innere Rolle dran gebastelt, damit es noch länger ist. Wow, du Heimwerker, die ein Weichen. Weil es hat jetzt fünf Zentimeter, wo du denkst, ja gut, dann sieht man trotzdem noch meine langen, beschissenen, verfilzten Haare um die Ecke. Das will ich ja nicht. Ich will ja Leute beobachten, ohne gesehen zu werden. Vor allem, also das war ja wirklich nicht so lang und auch das Sichtschwell war nicht so gross und das war ja da, dass man um die Ecke gucken konnte, deswegen heisst es ja um die Ecke gucken, und dieses um die Ecke gucken macht ja gar nicht so viel Sinn, weil also ich denke mal, wenn du um die Ecke guckst, gibst du ja auch nicht so viel Preis von deinem Gesicht und wenn da jetzt so ein neongrünes Ding einfach um die Ecke kommt, ist es glaube ich wesentlich auffälliger, als wenn du einfach kurz um die Ecke guckst. Ja, das stimmt. Ich glaube, um die Ecke wird in den nächsten Generationen noch ein viel grösseres Thema, weil es werden ja schon Waffen entwickelt, so Gewehre, die so ein Scharnier haben, und wo man dann so ein Display hat, wo man sieht, so eine Kamera vorne, wo man dann einfach um die Ecke schiessen kann. Ich glaube, die Kriegsführung wird hauptsächlich um die Ecke betrieben werden. Also jedes Land hat eine grosse Ecke, wo dann einfach alle Soldaten stehen und andere Länder beschießen, auch Artillerie mit so gekrümmten Rohren und so, die alle einfach um die Ecke schiessen. Ich glaube, das wird einfach ein grosses Thema werden in der Zukunft. Deswegen schon früher das Sprichwort, glaube ich, von, wer war es, Nietzsche, glaube ich. Man muss auch mal um die Ecke denken können. Das glaube ich, danke da an der Stelle, an unseren Hörer Nietzsche. Friedi, geile Sau. Ich hatte noch, weil ich wieder in so einer Abbo-Falle gefangen war, von Audible, hatte ich noch zwei Hörbuchplätze frei. Ja, kenn ich gut, ja, kenn ich gut.
Und dann habe ich das jetzt gemacht, musste mir auf die schnelle zwei Hörbücher kaufen.
Sehr lustige Bücher waren bei der Idee. Und dann habe ich mir das angehört, das eine, und das habe ich im ersten Kapitel bereits verloren.
Aber aus dem Grund, es ging halt darum, dass es war offensichtlich sehr autobiografisch, wie der gelispelt hat, der hat ein Sprachproblem, die Hauptperson, ist dann zu einem Logopäden gegangen. Und da hat der Logopäden dann angefangen, ihm zu sagen, nein, das spricht man so nicht aus, das heißt anders. Und dann hat er wieder gelispelt und dann hat der Logopäden ihm wieder geholfen. Aber es hat der Autor gelesen, das Buch, der offensichtlich immer noch diese Sprachfehler hat.
Das heißt, der ganze Sketch, diese ganzen 80 Seiten lustiger Dialog hat nicht funktioniert, weil er den Logopäden nicht deutlich sprechen lassen konnte, weil er auch lispelt. Es ergibt absolut keinen fucking Sinn. Das ganze Buch ergibt keinen Sinn. Die ersten 100 Seiten sind völlig für den Arsch, weil du es nicht verstehst. Weil die ganzen Gäste keinen Sinn machen, weil der Leser, weil der Autor lispelt. Also das heißt, der Autor ist ja auch dann irgendwann zum Logopäden gegangen, aber der konnte ihm trotzdem nicht helfen. Ja, augenscheinlich und die ganze Zeit schwingt halt in deinem Kopf noch die Geschichte mit, was danach wohl passiert ist, weil offensichtlich er nicht helfen können. Also ich glaube, ich glaube, das ist, was da alles so mitschwingt an Gedanken, die du dabei hast, du kannst dem Buch auch gar nicht mehr folgen.
Das ist echt hart.
Aber das fand ich wirklich lustig, ich musste irgendwann lachend einfach aufhören mit dem Buch. Einschlafen irgendwann. Lachend eingeschlafen, ja. Das ist echt so crazy gewesen. Wow, abgefahrene Geschichte. Hast du auch so... Ich hatte auch mal die Audible-Falle, war ich auch mal gefangen. Wir haben eine Audible-Falle gef wo du ja irgendwie 10 Euro im Monat zahlst und dann kannst du dir ein kostenloses Hörbuch aussuchen, was die normalerweise 4,99 Euro kosten, was ein richtig guter Deal ist. Ja, kann ich nur empfehlen und dann kann man irgendwie, dann vergisst man es und dann zahlt man irgendwie 40 Euro und dann denkt man auch fuck, jetzt muss ich mir noch vier hören, die hört man dann eh nicht an und dann kann man, ist dann endlich befreit, also der Befreiungsgefühl ist ganz geil, wenn du zum Abo fallend daraus bist. Du kannst aber auch erst das Abo stornieren, wenn du, was auch Sinn macht, deine zwei Hörbücher noch eingelöst hast. Aber es gibt so einen Zusammenschnitt von, also sprach Zarathustra, wo die so ein paar die Best-ofs, die Best-Bits, gesprochen von Otto Clemens, dem glaube ich besten Sprecher der Welt, der auch immer diese Tierdokus spricht, mega geile Stimme, die kann man sich gut reinziehen. Der ist der Typ, der eigentlich bei Zebra, Nilpferd und Co, der Typ, der da einmal spricht, der die tiefste Stimme der Welt hat, ein Nasson-Baby, mhm, und dann aber auch selten, einfach selten irgendwie versucht, mit seinen Off-Texten die Geschichte weiterzubringen, sondern einfach oft auch Laute macht, süss, die Robbenbabys sind schon wieder draußen, aah, so, so, so. Wenn dafür die ganze Zeit massiert wird. Achtet einmal drauf, wie der spricht immer, als ob der die ganze Zeit genau dabei massiert wird oder sowas, weil er gerade einfach irgendwie so ein super Entspannungs-Mode ist und dann einfach dann anfängt, diese Dinge einzusprechenprechen. Oh, die Zebras sind endlich draußen. Wow, Sonne, Sonne, Sonne, Sonne, Sonne. Aufs Bäuchlein scheinend. Was ist los mit den Leuten? Ich kenne die Sendung leider überhaupt nicht, deswegen ist es mega strange. Ruh dir das mal an. Aber es klingt auf jeden Fall sehr unterhaltsam, finde ich eine ganz gute Sache. Das ist der grösste Podcast-Filler übrigens, wenn beide zum Getränk greifen und dann
einfach zehn Minuten still ist. Ja, das fluchtig aus Angst zum Getränk greifen. Aber du bist ja kurz davor, ein Synchronsprecher-Seminar teilzunehmen, weil du möchtest dich ja thematisch neu orientieren. Ich kann dir privat nichts mehr erzählen, weil du alles sofort raus aus in dem Podcast. Aber das ist genau dieser Lispel-Effekt, dass die Zuschauer genau wissen, oh, bis Folge Mit 63 war er scheisse und schlecht, aber Abfolge 64 ist er ein neuer Mensch und erzählt alles anders. Das ist ein Seminar, was ich belege, also einfach so ein Workshop, wo ich eingeladen wurde, weil... Weil Leute, die den Podcast gehört haben und gesagt haben, das kann sich ja keine so andere... Das ist ein Synchronsprechseminar und ich bin echt gespannt, was da so passiert. Es ist vor allem von jemandem ... Das können wir ganz gut, synchron sprechen. Dass wir gleichzeitig sprechen, wir beide. Sag mal was. So, kommen wir jetzt zu unserer nächsten ... Wow, ich wollte dich gar nicht aufhalten. Und der Typ aber, der das macht, dieses Seminar, spricht auch manchmal für RTL2 diese Yu-Gi-Oh! Werbungen. Das heißt, das klingt dann meistens ungefähr so irgendwie, Yu-Gi-Oh! Die nächsten hundert Karten sind jetzt in diesem Pack! Yeah! Diese super abgespaceden, auf zehn Radbull befindlichen Sprecher, die immer die Yu-Gi-Oh! Werbung machen irgendwie, Yu-Gi-Oh! Oh mein Gott, was haben wir in diesem Pack? Es ist das Beste der Welt! Es ist das Beste der Welt und jetzt der grosse, schwarzköpfige Drache, jetzt in jedem siebten Pack! Und genau so würde der Podcast auch klingen ab der Fall. Und ich glaube, ab dann klingt irgendwie der Podcast so mega abgedreht die ganze Zeit. Wir sind ja eh schon als abgedreht bezeichnet worden. Ich glaube, der spricht auch so privat. Ich glaube, da könnte man auch 14 gute Sketchefs. Hey Stefan, herzlich willkommen zum neuen Synchronen-Workshop! Synchronen-Workshop eins für 35 Euro nur für Schnitten!
Ja, bin nicht schlecht.
Aber ich glaube, da kannst du eine Menge lernen, da kannst du dich ein bisschen aufpeppen.
Weil manchmal wird dir vorgeworfen, dass du so ein bisschen gleichgültig bist.
Habe ich zumindest gehört von einer gewissen Maxime, die hat sich beschwert.
Ja, diese dumme Maxime, soll man anfangen so zu leben, dass andere wollen können, dass man, das ist aber auch echt ein bisschen sperrig, der Satz. Ich glaube, man kann es auch gut zusammenfassen mit, mein Gott, sei doch kein Arschloch, sei einfach kein Wichser, genau das ist eigentlich die Aussage. Wenn du mal vergleichst mit, sei einfach kein Wichser, du Arschloch, oder handel einfach nur noch dererlei Maxime, von dem du wollen kannst, dass das zum Allgemeinen witz werden kann, du dummes Arschloch. Es ist halt echt schon ein bisschen sperrig. Also an der Stelle schlecht gemacht, Kant. Was ist der am wenigsten tätowierte Satz? Welchen Satz haben sich die wenigsten Leute tätowieren lassen? Glaubst du, du könntest es auf Anhieb einen Satz sagen, den sich noch niemand tätowiert hat, nie? Wie kriege ich das Tattoo wieder, wie kriege ich Tattoos wieder weg? Ja, ist halt als Gag, glaube ich, haben sich bestimmte Leute tätowieren lassen. Als Witzchen. Als Witzchen, als Spässchen, als Ulk, haben sie gesagt, haben irgendwie, dieses Tattoo war keine gute Idee oder so, eigentlich mag ich keine Tattoos tätowiert oder sowas, bestimmt. Gag-Pioniere, die neu ins Land vorstoßen wollten des Tattoo-Humors, glaube ich, haben bestimmt so sowas gemacht. Tattoos, nein danke. Auch Gag, ne? Gegen Tattoos. Was würdest du dir am ehesten tätowieren lassen? Dich, dein Gesicht, aber ohne Brille. Danke. Ich würde mit deinem Gesicht tätowieren lassen, aber mit, äall mit einem grossen Schnäuzer. Ja, richtig schlecht. Und aber auch so die Augen anders, die Nase anders, dass es zum Endefeld einfach nur aussieht wie Magnum. Das sieht ja gar nicht so sehr aus wie ich, das sieht mehr aus wie Magnum. Ja, was bist du mit einem anderen Gesicht und einem sehr grossen Schnäuzer? Akzeptiere's. So so ein Pärchen, die wirkt sich gegenseitig und die sagt, warum habe ich ein Schnauzer? Ja, das ist so süchtig. Das ist doch Magnum, das bin gar nicht ich. Doch, doch Steffi, das bist du. Nee, das bist du. Aber halt mit ein paar neuen Accessoires. Warum habe ich eine Pistole in der Hand? Ich dachte, du bist doch eine starke, selbstbewusste Frau. Das ist das eine Mal im Urlaub, da haben wir doch mal Schiessen gemacht als Animation.
Du hast geschossen an dem Stand den ganzen Nachmittag und ich habe wieder langweilig daneben gestanden und konnte nichts machen. Ich habe gesagt, lass uns noch zur Porzellanausstellung gehen, aber du hast gesagt, nein, ich muss jetzt schiessen, ich muss schiessen, ich muss diesen großen Bären haben. Am Ende hast du den Bären erschossen. Nein, dann habe ich dir angeboten, auf der Porzellanausstellung zu schiessen. Nein, das ging auch nicht, weil du die Waffe nicht entfernen konntest. Du hast viermal gefragt, aber die Waffe hing an dem Seil und du hast dann am Ende auf den Bären geschossen und der Betreiber der Bude hat gesagt, so funktioniert das nicht, sie müssen die kleinen Häschen abschiessen. Du hast sie bedroht mit der Waffe. Ich finde, du bist ganz schön laut dafür, Fräulein, dass wir danach zehn Tage lang auf der Porzellanausstellung festgesetzt haben. Das war schönes Porzellan und denk dran, was wir Schönes gefunden haben. Du hast auch was gefunden, was dir gefallen hat.
Ja, ich habe eine Statue von mir in Porzellan gefunden.
Richtig.
Die aber eigentlich nicht so aussieht wie ich, weil die hat einen sehr grossen Schnäuzer wie Magnum. Ja, ist richtig. Aber trotzdem, ist doch schön, dass wir jetzt eine Statue von mir haben.
Ich glaube, daher kam auch die Tattoo-Idee, wo wir eigentlich angefangen haben.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, stimmt. Ja, stimmt.
Der schlechteste Impro-Typ der Welt.
Entschuldigung, ich muss ja lustig sein. Ich muss eine normale Stimme wieder haben. Es muss ja eine Frau sein, Frauen sind ja immer der. Ich bin einigeschleimter.
Ach ja, mein Gott, es ist ganz schön früh, aber merkst du was, man hat so ein bisschen
eine andere Stimme, man ist ein bisschen kratziger eigentlich.
Ich finde, also mir gefällt es gerade nicht so sehr, muss ich sagen, aus dem einfachen Grund, dass man so ein bisschen träge noch ist. Ja, es stimmt. Man ist nicht vom Tag gezeichnet, hat schon dreimal geweint, weil die Kollegen wieder einen gemobbt haben, man ist halt noch so ein bisschen in so einem, der Tag kann wohin führen, ich bin noch nicht richtig wach halt. Ja, man hat ja auch nach der Nacht irgendwie alles vergessen. Es ist so, als wäre es alles nie passiert. Es rückt ja alles so schlagartig weiter in die Vergangenheit. Ah, apropos Nacht. Ich kann mal gucken, wie ich diese Nacht geschlafen habe. Oh, stimmt. Dank meiner neuen Sleep Better App. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Stefan hat eine tolle App gefunden, wo er seinen Schlafhutmus observieren kann. Ja, und folgendes macht diese App. Die App weckt einen, wann es für dich am besten ist. Die analysiert deinen Schlafzyklus, weil du hältst das Handy, musst du die ganze Zeit in der Hand halten. Du musst die ganze Zeit neben das Kopfkitzel liegen. Und das nimmt Geräusche wahr und Bewegungen wahr. Und dadurch weiss es genau, wann du in der Tiefschlafphase befindlich bist und wann nicht. Und es weckt dich halt, wenn du in der Leichtschlafphase, das ist glaube ich nicht der korrekte Termin, aber dann weckt es dich und dann bist du wirklich am Tag. Selbst wenn du kürzer schläfst, du besser ausgeschlafen bist, weil es darauf ankommt, in welcher Phase du geweckt wirst. Also Statistiken. Durchschnittliche Schlafdauer, acht Stunden vierunddreißig. Du führst ein Leben, das ist unfassbar. Acht Stunden vierunddreißig und ich bin meistens immer noch zu müde. Ich habe, glaube ich, wirklich ein Schlafproblem. Durchschnittliche Schlafeffizienz 91 Prozent. Das ist ganz geil. Ich schlafe einfach durch, die ganze Nacht. Aber du hast auch ein Traumtagebuch, ne? Du schreibst ja ein Traum auf und ich habe mir das als Vorbild genommen. Ich führ jetzt auch wieder Traumtagebuch, aber Audio, ich nehme jetzt auf. Okay, spiel mal ab. Wir spielen's mal ab. Wir hätten so ein geiles Verspiel machen können, wo wir es einfach abgespielt haben. Warte. Komm mal her. Warum ins Mikro musst du es noch nur halten. Okay, hier ist mein Traum. Traumtagebuch, 30. Mai 2016. Gehe also rein, will den Geldbeutel holen. In dem Moment, in dem ich ihn nehmen will, hat schon jemand anders den Geldbeutel gelommen. Ich greife auch zu, wir rangeln so ein bisschen darum, die Frage entsteht, ist das wirklich mein Geldbeutel?
Mockenstopp, Mockenstopp. Das klingt, also vom Gesprochenen her, klingt es so ein bisschen so, als ob du gerade irgendwie so eine Antarktisexpedition machst.
Und dann irgendwie am dritten Morgen, wir schreiben den 13.nten oktober 1937 ich habe mittlerweile meinen linken arm gegessen so klingt es ein bisschen weil du gerade irgendwie dieses spannendes erlebt aber der inhalt ist das komplett gegenteil davon es wäre gerade so eine eisbeide gefallen ja aber es wird noch richtig gut weiss nicht ich nehme meinen führerschein aus dem geldbeutel und zeige ihm den von das bin ich. Er glaubt mir das nicht, sagt, du siehst überhaupt nicht so aus wie auf dem Foto. Er nimmt dann selber auch noch meinen Ausweis raus, der, wie wir wissen, alle seit 2013 abgelaufen ist. Wie wir wissen, sagt er sich selber. Er zeigt die Verfassung als fettes, langhaariges Mädchen zeigt, glaubt er mir also auch nicht. Wir entscheiden dann, den Barkeeper entscheiden zu lassen, der sagt aber relativ sofort, nee doch, das ist schon der, ich nehme den Geldbeutel, verlasse die Bar und gehe die Strasse entlang.
Was für ein detaillierter Traum aber.
Folgt mir allerdings, schliesst immer weiter auf, bedrohliche Situationen, kommt immer näher, ich drehe mich um, um sie zu konfrontieren, es kommt aus einer eine komische Szene wo wir so tanzartig aneinander vorbei springen irgendwas in der Richtung was ein bisschen seltsam ist auf jeden Fall kommt es zu einem Gespräch und ich sag so ja was geht ab was willst du von mir und dann sagt er es ist ein Mann sagt ja ich will 500 Euro und dann sag ich Nö, das geht nicht und dann sagt er, es ist ein Mann, sagt, ja, ich will 500 Euro. Und dann sage ich, nee, das geht nicht. Und dann sagt er, ja, okay, ich will 50 Cent. Dann fange ich an zu lachen und sage, ja, ist ein guter Gag eigentlich. Machen wir Folgendes, ich kaufe dir den Gag ab. Ich bin auf Twitter und ich kaufe dir den Gag ab. Für 500 Euro. Und ich bestimme eine Zahl und dann würfeln wir und wie oft, also die Augen der Würfel werden multipliziert mit der Zahl, das soll der Preis sein. Und dann sagt die Person ja, okay. Und jetzt im weiteren Verlauf des Gesprächs entwickelt sich diese Person langsam zu einer Frau. Also irgendwann ist sie einfach eine Frau, was ein bisschen merkwürdig ist. Auf jeden Fall schüttelt sie dann ganz viele Würfel in meinen Rucksack, so 20 Stück oder so, dann ruhe ich dann davon ein paar raus und sage ich, okay, sagen wir mal Multiplikator drei, dann würfel ich mit zwei Würfeln, zweimal eins gewürfelt, also zwei, also sechs Euro, sagt die, nee, auf gar keinen Fall, das ist viel zu wenig. Dann würfel ich mit mehreren Würfeln, dann kommt glaube ich raus, so 300 Euro oder sowas in der Richtung, das sagt, das ist in Ordnung, so viel Geld habe ich aber nicht dabei. So, und dann hört der Traum da auf, ich plane aber noch weiter, wie ich anbieten soll, dass ich das Ganze per Paypal überweisen könnte und überlegt parallel so, ah cool, dann habe ich ja auch gleich ihre E-Mail-Adresse, dann kann ich da ja weiter Kontakt aufnehmen. So was in der Richtung. Ja cool, tschüss. Ich bin einfach gegen Ende mehr creepy geworden. Alter, aber das ist echt, also das ist aber ein bisschen zu lustig jetzt, zu träumen. Du hast das doch nicht geträumt. Doch, genau so habe ich geträumt. Ich habe es direkt nachdem ich aufgewacht bin aufgenommen. Also niemand träumt auch so dezidiert. Dezidiert? Was soll das denn heißen? Ja, also so mega akkurat, Szene für Szene, ganz viel passiert, alles kannst du dir merken. Nee, aber wirklich, du kannst dir, wenn du direkt nach dem Traum dich erinnerst, kannst du dir das merken? Ich habe in der ersten Nacht Sleep Better App. Jetzt kommen Stefans crazy Träume. Ja, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, was ich geträumt habe, aber ich habe das noch nie gemacht. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass du mehr Übungen drin hast. Aber ich habe mir aufgeschrieben, was ich in der ersten Nacht geträumt habe. Ja, finde ich jetzt einfach nicht wieder, das ist aber auch eine Scheiss-App. Sehr gut. Die Neutralität ist gewahrt. tatsächlich, Hamm, Westfalen, da ist ein Tierpark und da habe ich geträumt, dass der mittlerweile da runtergekommen ist, das hat mir alles total leid, überall traurige Tiere, traurige Pfleger und dann habe ich dir versprochen, dass ich dir so einen Lernautomaten kaufe. Und jemand kam raus, dass es 20.000 Euro kostet, aber ich bin bei meinem Stolz geblieben, gut, den helfe ich, bin weggelaufen, habe hinter mir noch einen Park verwüstet. Ja, aber ohne Scheiss, ich bin ein bisschen sauer, dass meine Träume so ein bisschen lächerlich einfach sind. Nein, ich glaube, aber hast du die Wüste direkt nach dem Aufwachen aufgeschrieben? Instant. Na, ich habe erst noch Zähne geputzt. Ja, aber du musst doch was vor Augen haben, wenn du dich daran erinnerst, wie dieser Park aussah und so. Aber so wenig passiert da nur. Ja, runtergekommen, ich würde es so bezeichnen. Ja, ja, nee, aber, ja, okay. Ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht habe ich tatsächlich mehr Übung. Ich hatte tatsächlich zwei Träume an der Nacht, aber ich hatte keine Lust mehr, den anderen auch noch aufzuhören. Ja, aber ich habe jetzt die letzten zwei Nächte, aber auch gar nicht mehr, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, was ich gemacht habe. Also diese App hat jetzt nur einen Traum darin stehen. Da bin ich ein bisschen sauber als auf mein Unterbewusstsein. Aber ich finde es eigentlich schon ganz lustig, dass du sagst, ich spende diesem Zoo einen neuen Elefanten. Elefanten kosten 40.000 Euro. Ich spende euch einen
Kaugummiautomaten. Ich spende euch einen neuen Mülleimer an dieser Stelle. Tschüss! Einfach sehr teuer alles. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber diese Würfelsache finde ich nicht blöd. Also angenommen, du hast einen Laden und du gebietest an, dass du den Preis aufwürfeln können, sagen wir mit zwei Würfeln jeweils. Und wenn im Schnitt die Dinge unter sechs Euro wert sind in dem Laden, machst du Gewinn. Und das ist nicht blöd, weil Leute immer, glaube ich, gut, ich nehme diese CD im Wert von 12 Euro und die chancelischen Zwölfwürfel ist sehr gering. Kann sein, dass sie dann dazu greifen und andere Leute auch in den Laden beziehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es legal ist, ob man das darf. So ein Laden, wo die Preise nicht fest sind. Warum denn nicht? Ich weiß es nicht, wie Braucherschutz, keine Ahnung. Ist ja Glücksspiel dann im Endeffekt schon irgendwo, oder? Ist es nicht auch Glücksspiel an einer Kirmes Enten angeln? Im weisesten Sinne sehr illegal. Du weißt nicht, was unter der Ente ist. Da kann ja auch Hauptpreis unter sein. Naja, aber du musst die Ente erstmal fangen. Ich glaube, sobald du eine eigene Leistung erfüllen musst, ist es nicht mehr Glücksspiel. Würfeln hingegen braucht keine Leistung. Es gibt sehr gute Würfler. Wirklich? Mein Onkel war ein sehr guter Würfler. Ja. Man nannte ihn Wolfgang. Kannst du mal irgendwas erklären? Erklär mal irgendwas. Ich würde dich mal gerne, erklär mal, warte mal, erklär mal, wie eine Solarzelle funktioniert. Also, die Sonne spendet Wärme. Diese Wärme regnet hinab, quasi kann man sich vorstellen, auf die Solarzelle. Und da passieren dann gewisse Mechaniken. Also man muss sich vorstellen, da sind ganz kleine Mikroorganismen, die sagen, Yay, Sonne, wuhu, dann den Sonnengott anbeten und dabei ein Ritual feiern. So, bei diesem Ritual, muss man sich vorstellen, tanzen diese Mikroorganismen alle, die freuen sich. Wie heissen die Mikroorganismen? Er hält sich ja die Augen zu. Das ist unwichtig für die Story, glaube ich. Okay. Und die fangen dann an, so rumzutanzen und ihr Ritual zu feiern, um den Sonnengott zu würdigen. Und dabei entsteht Wärme, weil die halt auch in ihren kleinen Zelten, das bekennt man ja von Volksfesten, da entsteht immer ein bisschen Wärme. Und dadurch, dass sie auch sehr viel rumtanzen und so und auch viel Feuerwerk, weil die den Sonnengott lieben und denken, den müssen wir wirklich jetzt auch mal dann anfeuern, sonst geht der nächste Tag nicht wieder auf. Und das wäre fatal. Und dann fangen die an, die Feste zu feiern, Feuerwerk und so. Und diese Wärme greift man ab. Wie? Durch kleine Röhren. Also wie entsteht aus Wärme das Strom letztlich? Okay, die Wärme wird umgeleitet, wird dann gegen kalte Luft geleitet und dann entsteht Reibung. Warme und kalte Luft ergibt ja Reibung, man kennt das ja vom Gewittern. Da kommt ja auch ein Laden. Warme Luft steigt dann auf, oder was? Genau, Warme Luft steigt auf, wird weitergeleitet in Behältnisse, wo nur kalte Luft drin ist.
Da entstehen dann Reibungen.
Und da entstehen ganz kleine Mikrogewitter, würde ich sie nennen.
Mikrowitter?
Diese Mikrogewitter werden in Batterien gespeichert und dieser Strom landet dann bei dir und mir im Föhn zum Beispiel.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Gern. Erklär du uns doch mal die Inflation, ein einfaches Beispiel. Also, Banken haben Geld. Ja, Banken bekommen Geld. Banken, was sind Banken? Eine Bank ist eine Institution, die Geld hat. Die bekommt Geld. Und du kannst dir Geld leihen. Und die Sache ist die, was Banken machen, die sind ja clever, die wollen ja möglichst viel Geld verleihen, weil von jedem Geld, das sie verleihen, bekommen sie Zinsen und bekommen damit Gewinn. Aber im Moment ist der Leitzins doch ganz niedrig und die Zinsen sind auch gar nicht gut. Was machen denn die Banken in einer Zeit, wo man kaum Zinsen mehr bekommt für angelegtes Geld, hm? Zur Finanzkrise kommen wir gleich. Das heisst, die Bank hat ganz viel Geld von den Menschen, aber sie kann sich relativ sicher sein, dass nicht alle Menschen ihr Geld gleich wieder haben wollen. Das heisst, die Bank hat ganz viel Geld rumliegen, das sie eigentlich nicht braucht. Das heisst, sie kann das Geld verleihen. Aber dadurch, dass sie weiss, dass alle Menschen nicht das Geld gleich haben wollen, kann sie das Geld auch mehrfach verleihen. Das heisst, sie kann eigentlich mehr Geld herstellen. Das heisst, du zahlst jetzt 100 Euro ein bei der Bank und dann leiht die
Bank das Geld an ... nee, warte mal ... nee, du zahlst der Bank 100 Euro ein. So, dann hat die Bank
100 Euro. Die Bank sollte eigentlich das Geld für sich behalten und darauf warten, dass du wiederkommst und das Geld dir wiedergibt. Die Bank weiss aber, ich habe genug Geld in der Reserve, das sollte Stefan jetzt kommen, könnte ich ihm auch das Geld von Johann geben. Das heisst, die Bank kann dein Geld verleihen an mich, dann habe ich auch 100 Euro. Das heisst, du hast 100 Euro auf der Bank, ich habe 100 Euro in bar. Das heisst, aus den 100 Euro, die du eingezahlt hast, sind 200 Euro entstanden, weil du hast das Geld virtuell, hast du ja noch, kannst ja damit Sachen kaufen und ich habe das Geld auch bekommen. Das heisst, die Bank hat aus 100 Euro 200 Euro gemacht. Das heisst, es ist mehr Geld entstanden. Das heisst, die Bank kann das Geld, das sie hat, mehrfach verleihen und kann somit mehr oder weniger Geld erschaffen, weil sie kann Geld ganz viel auszahlen, ohne dass sie es notwendigerweise immer hat. Würden alle Menschen gleichzeitig ihr Geld von der Bank einfordern, hätte die Bank nicht genug Geld, weil sie das Geld mehrfach verliehen hat, weil sie ja immer nur so viel Geld zurückhalten muss, dass einzelne Leute Geld abheben können. Es ist aber sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass alle ihr Geld gleichzeitig abheben. Ausser zum Beispiel? Wenn das neue Linken-Park-Album rauskommt. So, dann wollen alle Geld. Dann machen alle Menschen Geld und dann bricht die Wirtschaft zusammen. Also die letzte grosse Finanzkrise? 2009, beziehungsweise 2007, 2009, beziehungsweise 2008, stand, weil alle Leute das neue Linken-Park-Album kaufen wollten und alle wollten ihr Geld und dann ist die Wirtschaft zusammengebrochen. Und das nimmt man Geldschöpfung und dadurch entsteht mehr Geld, die Bank kann einfach Geld erschaffen und die Leute können mit diesem Geld Sachen einkaufen. Das heisst, es entsteht immer mehr Geld, im Umkehrschluss wird Geld selbst immer weniger wert. Das heisst, im Laufe der Zeit wird Geld immer weniger wert und das nimmt man Inflation. Wenn du vor 100 Jahren 10 Euro gehabt hättest, wäre das wesentlich viel mehr wert gewesen, als wenn du heute 10 Euro hast. Auch weil es Reichmark sind und so, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Auf jeden Fall wird Geld immer weniger wert. Dankeschön. Diese, glaube ich, grösstenteils falsche Erklärung des Begriffs Inflation. Aber ich finde es gut, dass wir mal ein bisschen Fortschritt machen. Auf jeden Fall. Und noch mal ein bisschen was erklären. Wir müssen ja auch mal gucken, wie wir mit diesem Podcast weitermachen. Und bevor wir alles löschen, müssen wir auch gucken, was können wir den Zuschauern noch mitgeben. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass das Thema Finanzen eine große Rolle spielen wird, weil du und ich in massive Schwierigkeiten finanziell kommen werden. Spreadshirt, glaube ich, saugt uns leer. Nee, aber jetzt mal auch, abgesehen von deinen Witzchen, die du jetzt gerade machst, sowas wie Steuern, da haben wir beide ja ein extremes Problem und es ist auch einfach größtenteils falsch, was da läuft. Ja. Und ich habe echt keine Ahnung mehr, wie viel Geld ich de facto besitze. Es ist ja meinem Freund Sebastian Wiegmann so passiert. Der hatte ja grosse Steuerschulden, weil er irgendwie Geld bekommen hat, weil er gearbeitet hat und dann einfach Geld ausgegeben hat und so und hier und da und nicht darauf geachtet hat, Steuern zu zahlen und so. Und irgendwann kam die Steuer und gesagt, ja Leute, was ist denn hier los? Und dann zack, bam, ist er einfach mal von heute auf morgen irgendwie 20.000 Euro im Minus. Und dann stehst du ja erst mal da. Und das kann mir genau so passieren, exakt genau so und wird auch passieren. Deswegen ist meine Strategie... Wenn jemand vom Finanzamt diese Folge gerade hört. Florentin Will, Bankleitzahl. Das heißt, ich habe einfach ein sehr gutes Schloss an meiner Tür. Das heißt, er kommt gar nicht rein. Und ich habe einfach ganz viele Lincoln-Park-Alben gesammelt, dass wenn dieser Tag kommt, ich die einfach alle verkaufen kann, so dass ich dann Geld habe, mit denen ich die Schulden bezahlen kann. Du warst ja auch mal Anteilseigner eines Unternehmens, ne? Hast du mir erzählt, dass ich angefangen habe, dir zu erzählen, dass ich mich in Aktien umgesehen habe? Und du hast massiv viel verloren, weil die Firma wegen die unter anderem Platte gegangen ist, korrekt? Ja, da sind wir bei Solarzellen, ich habe Anleihen einer Solarfirma gekauft, weil ich dachte, das ist ja offensichtlich die Zukunft. Ich meine, Öl gibt es ja bald nicht mehr und Sonne gibt es immer. Also ist es ja offensichtlich die Zukunft und offensichtlich wird da viel hinein investiert, auch für die Regierung und so, erneuerbare Energien und so. Das heißt, es ist eine sichere Bank, Solar ist einfach ein, da gibt es keine Alternative. Das ist ein Brett, hat ein Steuerberater mir gesagt. Er hat gesagt, ja, hier, nimm einfach mal Anleihen. Anleihen ist natürlich nicht so sehr wie Aktien, weil Aktien sind ja von Aktien kursabhängig, wohingegen Anleihen, da kriegt man ja im Vorhinein so eine grosse Tabelle, wie viel die an jedem Tag wert sein werden. Also du kannst genau gucken, wenn ich die jetzt kaufe und in 14 Jahren verkaufe, habe ich 14% Gewicht oder so ein Kram. Wobei das so eine Mischung aus Worst-Szenario und Best-Szenario ist. Ja, genau. Aber es ist eher sowas wie ein Versprechen, als jetzt wie Poker, wie bei Aktien. Jemand verspricht dir was und du sagst, ja, der ist glaubwürdig, dieses Versprechen glaube ich, nehme ich an. So, Firma ist relativ sofort pleite gegangen, mein gesamtes Geld war weg und seitdem laufen halt irgendwo in der ganzen Welt Prozesse gegen diese Firma und in diese ...
Von denen du aber für immer das mitbekommst, weil du ja Anteil sagst.
Von denen ich das mitbekomme, weil ich bin ja Anteil sagst. Ich krieg dann immer so einen Brief, der sagt so, ja, bitte wählen Sie einen Vertreter der Investoren.
Und dann stehen da einfach zwölf Namen und einen Kreuzern an und schickst es ab und dann habe ich aber auch schon mal einen.
Ja, aber heute ist die grosse Wir-erzählen-alle-Geschichten-nochmal-Folge, weil Hörer sich das gewünscht haben. Erzähl du doch mal die Geschichte, wie du zusammengeschlagen wurdest. Nein, die erzähle ich an einem besonderen Tag. Das ist, glaube ich, die beste Geschichte, die du hast, oder? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Es ist die spannendste Geschichte, die ich habe. Und auch die, wo man auch mal schmunzeln kann. Da kann man sehr schmunzeln und ich habe im Endeffekt 1000 Euro rausgeholt. Die du aber noch nicht bekommen hast. Die ich noch nicht bekommen habe, wo man auch mal in diesem Podcast, glaube ich, mal telefonieren, ein paar Telefonstreichen machen könnte, wie ich hier diese 1000 Euro bekomme, die mir noch zustehen.
Kann ich mal erzählen, in einer eigenen Folge, die wir nennen, Zusammenschlagen, so heißt die Folge, und da erklären wir euch, wie man sich schützen kann, wie man sich am besten totstellt, was man am besten für Warnfarben trägt, damit das nicht passiert, dass man immer einen Helm tragen sollte, immer ein Kick-Me-Post-It-Bag-Macher, das braucht quasi. Oder so ein T-Shirt, ich bin gut versichert. Ich bin gut versichert, ich habe einen guten Anwalt, solche Sachen einfach. Ja, ist glaube ich die beste Abwehr einfach. Das wäre auch immer, man liegt ja manchmal, wenn man so durch dunkle Gassen läuft, was würde man machen, wenn jetzt wirklich jemand auf dich zukommt und sagt, ich schlage dich zusammen oder ich bring dich um. So läuft sowas ab.
Ich würde dann wirklich immer sagen, meine Verdeingung wäre immer so, Alter, ist dir das wirklich wert, mich zusammenzuschlagen, dafür, dass es eine Kängel ist.
Da ist eine Kamera, da ist eine Kamera, herzlich willkommen bei Pranktime.
Ich meine, ich werde es auf jeden Fall überleben, ich habe schon Schlimmeres als dich überlebt, du Bakko, und deswegen, ich werde dich anzeigen.
Ich habe ein gutes Gedächtnis.
Ich glaube auch, dass, also ich überlege auch oft, wie ich mich damals verhalten hätte, wenn ich Teil einer Schlacht gewesen wäre. Und ich glaube, ich hätte mich einfach instant totgestellt, weil du musst dir dir vorstellen, die meisten Leute da ... Sind noch im Ansturm. Die meisten Leute da wollten ja nicht kämpfen, die meisten Leute wurden gezwungen von dem Land, sondern gab es diese Braveheart-Reden, wow, ihr seid alle so sauer auf dir, sind eure Feinde und so. Aber mal ganz im Ernst, wie viele Prozent, glaubst du, haben das wirklich geglaubt? Es kommt jetzt stark auf die Armee und die Schlacht an, aber ich glaube, es war nicht immer so. Aber ich glaube auch so in Nazi-Deutschland, dass da auch viele Leute dachten, ja, ich muss jetzt halt hier mitmachen, weil sonst ich einfach tot bin. Ich glaube, am Anfang war da schon noch viel ideologische Verblendung mit dabei und
Stolz und Vaterland. Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass wenn ich
in der Schlacht gewesen wäre, dass ich mich dann
und ich glaube, war das
auch damals einfach, dass sich sehr viele Leute
quasi sobald der erste Feind
vorhin stand, sich einfach totgestellt haben. Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so
klar, weil du einfach zertrampelt wirst, also
wenn es aus der Mittelalter nicht war. Ja, und dann daraus, ich wäre immer am Rand
gewesen. So, ich hätte mich immer an den Rand gestellt,
bewusst. Ja, gut, das ist nämlich mit deiner Entscheidung. Und dann wäre ich durch den nächsten Wald einfach geflohen. Ja, und dann? Was machst du dann? So, und dann Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, wäre immer am Rand gewesen. So, ich hätte mich immer an den Rand gestellt, bewusst. Und dann wäre ich durch den nächsten Wald einfach geflohen.
Ja, und dann? Was machst du dann?
So, und dann, wenn die Schlacht vorbei ist, lege ich mich dazu und tue verletzt.
Dann würde ich mich vielleicht in den Arm schneiden und dann sagen,
wow, bin gerade erst wieder zu mir gekommen. Was ist los, Leute?
Haben wir gewonnen oder nicht?
Und dann würde ich sagen, sorry, mir war echt übel. Und dann bin und dann bin ich ja am Start, aber bei der nächsten Statt würde ich es ja machen. Man würde sich alle wundern, warum ich so viele Schlachten überlebt habe, aber das wäre es mir wert. Ja. Warum hast du das nicht vor 3000 Jahren gesagt, als die Ägypter und die Pharisäer gekämpft haben? Weil ich glaube, dann wären wir nicht weiter heute im Leben, weil sie andauernd alle zurückgestellt hätten und die Schlachten einfach... Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht alle totstellen, dann treffen wir uns dann morgen nochmal wieder. So macht's keinen Spaß. Alle drei Armeen in dieser Trippelschlacht, hier stellen sich alle konstant tot. Was soll das? So macht's keinen Spaß, so will ich nicht gewinnen. Aber Leute, dann lassen wir's halt. Wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, dann habe ich auch keinen Bock. Dann gehen wir halt wir halt heim. Mein Gott, ey. Die meisten schlachten heim. Wollt ihr Karthago zerstören oder nicht? Ja, ich würde es nicht. Ja, und dann machen wir morgen halt nochmal. Ich glaube auch, dass Vergewaltigung einer der grössten Motoren der Menschheitsgeschichte war, weil die einfach Städte geplündert und vergewaltigen durften, wie sie wollten. Und wenn du in so einer Armee bist, mit nur Männern und so ein paar Trosshuren oder sowas, aber einfach die Vorstellung, die ist da rein, vergewaltigst, alles, was nicht bei drei irgendwie auf dem Turm ist, ist, glaube ich, ganz gut. Ich glaube, seitdem Vergewaltigung eher so kritisch beäugt wird, haben viele Armeen ein Motivationsproblem. Weil du kannst ja nicht schlecht zur Bundeswehr sagen, hier, wir fallen in den Irak ein, wir können da vergewaltigen, wie ihr Bock habt, da würden sich viele Leute melden. Aber an sich geht das heute schlechter. Ihr kriegt den Mindestlohn. Ja, nicht. Und ihr habt eine coole Waffe, ratatatatatatat. Die macht bumm bumm bumm. Die trifft ab und zu. Kritisch, satirisch, für mich war alles drin in dem Gag, gut, das war's. Das war's. Wir enden mit einem spitzen satirischen Gag. Mit einer kleinen Spitze geschossen in Richtung Politik. Aber bei Florentin ist es auch so, wenn du manchmal nicht aufpasst, was er dort macht neben dir, in der Arbeit, wo alle Leute Gags schreiben und so, sitzt er dann einfach irgendwann da und dann guckt, was macht er denn da, warum hat er sich zehn Minuten nicht mehr gesagt, dann guckt er sich einfach ein Video von einer Schlacht an oder von der Bundeswehr und irgendwie so YouTube-Schlacht von der Bundeswehr. Ja, er guckt sich dann irgendwie an, so die Schlacht von Verdun oder halt anderen Scheiss. Man weiss nicht genau, was das soll. Also dann hast du einfach dann irgendwie so ein YouTube-Video offen. Das ist, glaube ich, ziemlich für Schlachten und so Kriegsgedöhn, was ein bisschen gruselig ist. Du wärst jemand, in der Schule hätte ich Angst, du irgendwann mal mit einer Waffe in die Schule kommst und dann einfach alle niedermetzelst. Nein, ich glaube, die, die sich wirklich für Militär interessieren, sind die, die am letzten sowas machen, weil die auch einschätzen können, was da für Horrorszenarien am Ende da rauskommen und wie tragisch das am Endeffekt ist. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, ich glaube nicht, dass das der klassische Amokläufer ist, der sich für Waffen interessiert. Wir hatten damals in der Klasse jemanden, der sehr dick hieß Rico, was eigentlich schon sehr lustig war,
wirklich voll das Programm, rote Haare, mega dick, mega unsympathisch, super Nerd spielt, hat nur Ballerspiele gespielt, Sprachfehler,
wirklich der grösste asoziale Typ, mega uncool zu allen Leuten und hat einfach Ballerspiele gespielt und hat in der Freizeit geschossen. Er war wirklich, also er war Schütze und es war wirklich allen klar, dass wir irgendwann mal, wir haben ihn alle gemobbt, kontinuierlich jeden Tag, es war wirklich ganz schön furchtbar. Eigentlich war das so der Lehrbuch-Amok-Schütze, der irgendwann mal, und das wäre wirklich so etwas gewesen, er hat das gemacht und danach hätten Leute gefragt, Rico, ja, passt. Das hätte niemand in Frage gestellt, diese ganzen Geschichten mit, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass alles gemacht hätte, das hätte bei uns alles nicht, wäre nicht gewesen, es wäre einfach so, ja, gut. Ihr habt dann auch in der Klasse schon so Interviewtraining gemacht, wenn die Reporter kommen und euch fragen, was ihr dann sagen müsst.
Und diese Rosen niederlegen, habt ihr alle schon geprobt. Ich fand es auch so lustig, dass einer so offensichtlich Amokläufer ist in der Klasse, dass alle anderen Schüler so kugelsichere Westen tragen immer so. Die ganze Zeit auch. Nur so. Warum habt ihr diese Helme von der S.E.K. mit diesem Plexigl? In Mode, einfach warum habt ihr so einen riesigen Schild irgendwie die ganze Zeit gegen mich gerichtet? Warum ist Rico in einem grossen Plexiglaswürfel?
Also ganz unauffällig, irgendwie so tragen Helme, versuchen sie sich so provisorisch irgendwie so eine Rüstung zu bauen, alle anderen Schüler.
Einfach so, das finde ich eigentlich auch nicht schlecht. Aber wirklich, also es hat mich nicht gewundert, es hat niemanden gewundert, wenn das passiert wäre irgendwann.
Aber hattet ihr mal so eine Amoklaufübung bei euch in der Schule? Hatten wir auch.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, nach dem Winnenden-Anschlag. Ja, genau, Winnenden, glaube ich, war da ein grosser Umroh. Und bei uns war es, das Codewort war Bibi Blocksberg. Ah, fuck, yo, da gab es ein Codewort. Verdammt, wie gut ist das denn? Stimmt! Das war auch schon so. Richtig. Was so dämlich ist, war ja, der Amokläufer per Definition das Codewort auch kennt, weil er auch Schüler dieser Schule ist. Das haben wir auch gesagt, ja, das war aber auch ein Thema bei uns, aber dann hieß es, im Adrenalin vergisst du das dann. Vergisst du, wie wir Blocks bergen wollen. Aber vor allem denke ich mir auch, gut, weil der Amokläufer der einzige ist, der unter Adrenalin steht, wenn er gerade in der Schule, nicht dass die Schüler auch alle irgendwie Angst haben und unter ihnen das Cold-Wolf-Leicht vergessen. Ja, vor allem ist es nicht total dumm, seinem Gegner die Verteidigungsmassnahmen zu zeigen und zu proben, damit er sich genau ausmacht, ich weiss ich weiss exakt, was die Leute machen sollen. Ja, aber was hätten die machen sollen sonst? Also hätten die alle Leute wie Rico oder einfach in den Raum, kommt mal alle kurz mit, wir gehen kurz an zu Rutsche und die anderen, die machen kurz die Amoklaufübung. Das ist eigentlich nicht doof, ja genau so. Wir warten alle, bis Rico mal krank ist und dann machen wir diese Übung. Dann machen wir die Amoklaufübung. Die Rico-Übung. Also Rico kommt hier durch die Tür oder der Amoklau, je nachdem und dann machen wir das und das. Finde ich so schlecht, so wie so eine konstante Gefahr in der Klasse. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ja, aber was hätten die sonst machen sollen? So eine grosse Puppe, die auch genauso aussieht wie Rico, die dann so zur Tür reint. Aber ich versuche nochmal das Passwort bei uns rauszufinden, das gab es nämlich auch auf jeden Fall. Aber was ich auch immer seltsam fand, was immer ein Fragezeichen war in der Schulzeit war, dass im ersten Stock, im zweiten Stock ein Fenster nicht zu öffnen war, aus Selbstmordschutzgründen und ein Fenster aber immer offen bleiben musste wegen Feueralarm. Das heißt, es war immer ein Fenster offen und ein Fenster zu. Einfach Tod und Leben direkt visualisiert. Genau, Tod und es scheint auch drüber tatsächlich, ich weiß auch nicht wo. Aber ohne Scheiss, wie grossartig ist das eigentlich?
Ein Fenster muss. Einfach Tod und Leben direkt visualisiert. Genau, Tod und es scheint auch drüber tatsächlich, ich weiß auch nicht, aber ohne Scheiss, wie grossartig ist das eigentlich?
Ein Fenster muss immer zu sein, Selbstmord, ein Fenster muss immer auf sein, wegen Feuerschutz.
Leute, dann lasst es doch einfach. Aber was waren denn, welche Unterrichtsräume, also welche Unterrichtsräume hatten die höchste Selbstmordgefahr?
So nach Fächern organisierte Physik.
Physik durfte kein Feuerschutz scheissegal.
Protonen, nein, raus aus dem Fenster, direkt tot. Krass. Aber da habe ich auch nicht verstanden, genau, warum das so war. Aber das sind halt diese Regelungen, die versuchen, das Leben besser zu machen, sich aber kontinuierlich widersprechen und das im Endeffekt ausgleichen. Im Endeffekt ist alles so gut und schlecht, wie es vorher war. Bei uns in der Grundschule wurden zwei Mitschülerinnen von ihrer Mutter getötet. Das ist kein Witz, wirklich mit einer Axt. Die Mutter ist amok gelaufen und hat die Kinder ihren Mann und den Hund getötet. Und das war es dann, dann waren die weg, waren Zwillinge. Und dann waren wir mega jung, ich glaube vierte Klasse oder so, echt sehr jung noch. Ja, wohl vierte Klasse ist man ja erst mal elf, vielleicht schon, ne? Vielleicht schon früher irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, also da weiß ich noch. Und es war so ganz surreal, weil heute, wenn das passieren würde, mega Tragödie, total krass Trauma. Aber damals hat man das gar nicht so realisiert. In Bayern, das ist auch so ein bisschen, ja gut. Aber das war dann immer so so gruselig. Das war halt der eine Fall, den es zehnmal im Jahr gibt, okay. Das waren dann immer so die Horror-Stories, weil man nicht wusste genau, was mit dieser Mutter dann los ist. Und dann so die Axtmörderin ist noch unterwegs und ist im Wald und so, wenn man sich da Geschichten erzählt und sowas in der Richtung und dann ist man immer so in den Wald gegangen, so wer traut sich dahin, auch da, wo die gewohnt haben und so, es war schon strange, aber die waren auch ein bisschen weird, die Zwillinge, das war schon komisch, aber das war auch so. Ich war nie weg plötzlich einfach, dann waren die Plätze leer. Ich hab diese Scherenproblematik gerade in meinem Kopf, also es denken Leute, dass sie Gags darüber machen gerade, was wir nicht tun. Und dann heisst es wieder, ihr seid völlig verkommen. Ich hör schon wieder die Stimme in meinem Kopf. Ihr seid völlig verkommen. Das finde ich mal einen Kommentar, den ich gar nicht so schlecht finde. Ihr seid völlig verkommen. So, das kann ich machen. Ja nein, es passieren einfach nicht nur fröhliche Dinge im Leben. Manchmal ist es auch doof. Manche Tage sind doof. Aber dafür sind ja so Sachen wie wir da, einfach so Leute, die einfach stumpf unterhalten wollen. Ja, einfach mal so Hayopay, wie Amok läuft. Wir haben Hitler schon Hayopay genannt. Ich weiß, aber ich dachte, den Teil schneiden wir raus, wegen Hitler. Hitler ist ein Einschalter. Das stimmt, bei Minute 23 gibt es Hitler. Aber wie sahen dann die Amok-Übungen aus eigentlich bei euch? Also hat man auch, weil ich meine, jeder, also das war so meine Vorstellung, jeder in der Klasse hat sich immer vorgestellt, ja, ja gut, verkriecht euch ihr unter den Stühlen, wenn der reinkommt, dann kämpfe ich gegen den oder werfe einen Stuhl auf den und ich bin der grosse Held und mache den fertig. Habe ich mir zumindest immer vorgestellt, dass ich dann der grosse Held bin, der sich dann vor die anderen Stühle wird. Nee, ich habe immer sofort gedacht, also macht euch, macht euch, macht euch eure Übungen, ich nehme Saskia als Schutzschild und dann geht gar nichts mehr. Genau, alle verstecken sich Reflex eigentlich hinter der dicken Saskia. Ich nehme fette Saskia einfach als Schutzschild. Ja, aber ohne Scheiss, da kommt wieder meine Theorie. Ich finde, mit einer Theorie kann ich mittlerweile gut leben, alle Menschen sind Egoisten, dann darf ich auch Egoist sein, weil es ja halt zwangsläufig in meiner menschlichen Natur liegt. Und dann nehme ich einfach Saskia und dann, ja, na eh.
Also das wäre so gut, einfach so ein Testalarm, okay, B-Blockswerk und die gesamte Klasse reflexartig hinter Saskia und Saskia so, oh Leute, ernsthaft?
Aber sie hat auch so ein Rettungsbein auf ihrem Rücken kleben die ganze Zeit.
Und hat auch so eine Zielscheibe auch auf ihr, ein T-Shirt.
Du musst die ganze Zeit dieses Leibchen tragen, in Form einer grossen Zielscheibe.
Einer muss sich opfern, Saskia.
Warum steht der Kimi?
Bei uns war es, glaube ich, wirklich dann so, Bibi Blocksberg steht dann stellvertretend für den Amokläufer.
Also Bibi Blocksberg ist in den Gängen, Bibi Blocksberg ist in der Kantine oder so ein Kram.
Was dann auch so, plötzlich hatten alle mega Angst vor Bibi Blocksberg, weil sie sich alle vorgestellt haben, dass Bibi Blocksberg mit so einer AK-47 zur Tür reinkommt und die Schüler niedermäht. Oder es gibt einen grossen Bibi-Worstberg-Fan in der Klasse, bei dem das komplette Gegenteil auslöst, sondern der einfach in den Flur rennt. Ja, sie ist endlich da! Und kann der Amokläufer dann auch zaubern? Nein, Patrick, es ist nur ein Codewort. Und der hat dann den Bösen dabei oder was? Nein, Patrick.
Es gibt ja oft auch von Staaten und so Videos, die irgendwie helfen sollen oder so schützen sollen,
Don't Drink and Drive, diese verschiedenen Aufklärungsvideos. Und es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennen, das ist relativ bekannt, auf YouTube auch zu finden,
kanadische Videos von einem Government in Kanada, die halt auch so ein Aufklärungsvideo gemacht haben, aber halt so ein bisschen, also die Message ist am Ende nicht ganz klar. Aber es ist eher sowas wie, mach keine Fehler, als irgendwie, als Don't Drink and Drive.
Es ist keine klare Message, es ist einfach eine Frau in der Küche, die einfach die ganze Zeit locker erzählt, wow, sie macht Spaß, sie kocht gerade irgendwas und dann rutscht sie aber auf Wasser aus, dann mega krass wird einfach die Kamera aufgehalten, wie sie mit dem Kopf gegen die Küchenplatte stürzt, einfach überall Blut, das ganze Gesicht ist aufgerissen, das ist das krasseste, obszönste, was ich jemals gesehen habe. Kein Horrorfilm kommt da dran, aber es ist einfach die kanadische Regierung hat das gemacht und am Ende steht dann da, seien Sie immer vorsichtig überall. Und dann ist einfach, Alter, was ist los bei euch? Die Message ist, mach bitte einfach keine Fehler vielleicht. Ja, das ist nicht so falsch. You wouldn't download a car. Das war auch gut, diese Raubkopierwerbe kam man hier damals. Mittlerweile hat man das ja komplett aufgegeben, gegen Raubkopierer irgendwie zu warnen oder so. Aber damals in den 90ern, als das aufkam irgendwie, you wouldn't download a car. I would if I could. So what? If I could download a car, maybe I would do it. Das ist auch immer so, dass man die Prämisse nicht versteht, weil die Idee an Raubkopieren ist ja, du klaust etwas, ohne es jemand anderem wegzunehmen. Das ist ja das moralische Problem an Raubkopieren. You wouldn't download a car. You wouldn't steal a car. Nein, weil das ist ja klauen, weil dann hat der andere ja kein Auto mehr. Das ist moralisch eine ganz andere Sache, als wenn ich irgendwie was klaue. Niemand fehlt was, aber dafür ist irgendwie die Filmindustrie geschädigt. Das ist moralisch eine ganz andere Abstraße. Genau das Aufklärungsvideo immer ist, wir geben dir die Lösung mit, don't drink and drive, you can drive but don't drink. Or you can drink but don't drive. Ja, aber wohingegen diese Werbekampagne einfach mitliefert, bitte mach einfach nichts falsch in deinem Leben, rutsch nicht auf Wasser aus, was random in deiner Küche versteuert ist. Bitte verstoß gegen die Gesetze, büdde, dange, dange, dange, dange, dange.
Gibt es eigentlich eine sehr höfliche Version des Grundgesetzes?
Hey, ich weiss nicht, ob ihr...
Ich weiss, manche Menschen sind riesen Arschlöcher, Leute.
Aber Leute, aber die haben auch Würde.
Menschenwürde, sorry, ist halt so.
Artikel zwei.
Ich habe euch hier mal ein paar Gesetze aufgeschrieben, schaut da mal drüber, ob dir was gefällt, guck einfach mal...
Schau mal drüber, solltest dich dran halten, nicht, dass du es falsch verstehst. Genau, guck einfach mal rein, ob dir was gefällt. Wenn du noch Verbesserungsvorschläge hast, reich dir einfach rein bei einem zuständigen Bundesamt. Hier ist StGB ein bisschen dick, aber guck einfach mal rein, ob es dir gefällt, irgendwie gegen Ende wird es ganz geil mit Betrug und so, da wird es ganz cool, aber schau einfach mal rein, vielleicht findest du eher was für dich. Ist ja auch eher sowas wie eine Motivation auch, so ein Gesetzbuch. Man will ja Gesetze brechen. Vielleicht ... Waren dir ... also Anwälte haben ja oft in ihren Kanzleien einfach die ganzen Gesetzbücher hinter sich stehen. Ich habe eine Anwaltskanzlei. Ich habe ein Praktikum gemacht, an einer Anwaltskanzlei. Was die ganze Zeit besteht, einfach die Anwaltsgehilfen sind, die ganze Zeit nur um Akten einsortieren. Also das ist wirklich, die meiste Zeit war ich damit beschäftigt, Akten einzusortieren. Also ich kann das Alphabet mittlerweile mega gut. Was kommt vor L? K. Oh wow, nicht schlecht. Was kommt vor P? O. Okay, was kommt nach N? O. Okay, ja gut, glaube ich dir jetzt einfach mal. Nicht schlecht. Aber das hat sich ja auch mit der Digitalisierung. Oh.
Okay, ja gut, glaube ich dir jetzt einfach mal. Nicht schlecht. Aber das hat sich ja auch mit der Digitalisierung komplett erledigt, oder? Nee, nee, nee. Das war vor drei Jahren oder so. Stimmt, du bist ja noch so ein Jungspund. Ja, das war noch nicht so lange her. Also die Akten werden weiterhin Bestand haben. Aber das, ich fand es immer ein bisschen verwirrend, wenn Anwälte dann ein Buch vor sich aufgeschlagen haben, wo sie nachlesen müssen, wie der Gesetzestext aussieht. Ich meine, okay, es ist ihr Job, die können ja nicht alles auch auswendig wissen, aber es ist so ein bisschen, macht es das die kleiner. Ja. Weil gut, das können die auch nachlesen, dann wissen sie auch, wie die Gesetzestlage ist, aber na ja, gut, das stimmt. Das ist genau so wie wie im Arzt so, ich habe hier so ein Ziehen im Nacken. Sekunde, ganz kurz, holt so ein Buch raus, was war der Nacken nochmal, was war das denn nochmal, so einen Nacken habe ich fucked, das ist eigentlich gar nicht. Geht nebenbei her? Können Sie nicht nacken, Herr? Sagen Sie Stopp, wo tut es Ihnen weh?
Genau, nacken, angenommen Sie müssen jemandem erklären, wo denn nacken wir.
Angenommen, wo würden Sie, sagen Sie Stopp, wo es Ihnen genau weh tut.
Das Ding, so viele Knochen. Wo tut's Ihnen weh? Genau. Nacken. Angenommen, Sie müssen jemandem erklären, wo denn Nacken... Angenommen, wo würden Sie... Sagen Sie Stopp, wo es Ihnen genau weh tut.
Das Ding.
So viele Knochen hat der Mensch. Das ist doch Quatsch, oder?
Das ist doch alles Unsinn hier, diese Rippen.
Ein oder zwei, aber nicht so viele.
Schwachsinn, ey. Wo habe ich dieses dumme Skelett her?
Bitch.
Ja, also ich bin eigentlich durch.
Ja, ich auch. Die Sonne geht langsam auf. Wir können den Tag, ist verrückt, ne, dass jetzt der Tag erst losgeht. Normalerweise gehen wir da eigentlich direkt ins Bett gemeinsam. Ja, aber wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind, wohin gehen wir jetzt? Ja, eigentlich will ich ja. Ins Bett. Naja, gut. Macht euch bereit. Also ich sage nur so viel, dieses Jahr hätten noch viele Beraschungen für euch. Ey, wir haben richtig was für euch in Planung, Leute. Haut mal ein paar Theorien raus. Mich würde es wirklich interessieren, was unsere Zuhörer so denken. Man fragt sich ja oft, was sind das für Menschen, aber dann immer so, ja, ich heiße Katrin und bin 19 Jahre alt und arbeite hier und da, das interessiert mich nicht. Ich will mal ein bisschen so, womit ihr euch beschäftigt. Was sind eure Theorien, was sind eure Gedanken, was sind eure Träume, Wünsche? Haut mal ein bisschen was raus, was ihr euch gedanklich so beschäftigt. Und haut einfach ein paar Lines raus, einfach ein paar Sätze, so Theorien, die man überprüfen kann, dann können wir darüber reden, ob wir dem zustimmen oder nicht. Und am Ende bringen wir so ein grosses Kaffeebuch raus, wo viele Bilder drin sind und am Ende im Abspann kommen dann so ein paar von euren Sätzen, das wäre doch ganz geil. Und so für euren Namen, also ihr habt die Crate, ihr gebt die Rechte hauptsächlich an uns ab, das muss man dazu sagen, das Claimer. Das muss man sagen, aber euren Namen findet ihr falsch geschrieben, hinten drauf nochmal am plattenden Text.
Wir waren Stefan und Marco von Das Podcast Ufo. Das ist mein Thema eben ab.
Macht's gut.